foreign
[Music]
it's been called the world's largest 3D
Puzzle but it's not a game the remains
of a British ship that set sail years
before Columbus was rediscovered two
decades ago and that's how long it's
taken to try and put it back together
again the BBC's Thomas Morgan has the
story
this is a one to ten scale model this is
a same-scale person about a six foot
tall person so this gives you an idea of
the size and scale well I'm above that
height so actually gosh I would just be
dwarfed so yeah you imagine at 30 meters
long Wing 25 tons when it's fully
rebuilt Newport will have the only 15th
century ship on exhibit anywhere in the
world
but with 2 500 individual pieces the
challenge now will be putting it back
together this one is basically like a
huge flat pack jigsaw puzzle without
instructions we have a big challenge
here in that this is the uh really as
far as I know the largest attempt to
reconstruct a uh wooden archaeological
ship
once it's been dry
it started off as hundreds but now
thousands of people are queuing outside
and it's to see this it's about dating
back to the 1400s the original wreck was
found back in 2002 whilst building for
the city's new Arts Center was taking
place on the edge of the river esk
workers came across the remains seven
meters deep in mud and it's taken the
best part of 20 years for each
individual piece of wood salvaged to go
through a lengthy process of soaking
waxing and drying so that it can be
reassembled safely
Toby and his team believe it was built
from Basque Country Wood launched around
1449 and involved in the lucrative wine
trade between Portugal and Bristol
fell into the water its thought whilst
being repaired in Newport dock later
that Century so this is the wow moment
what do you think much of the ship was
dried in Portsmouth on the Naval Base
which is home to the UK and possibly the
world's most famous 16th century ship
the Mary Rose
the museum builds around the naval
vessel has been a major tourist
attraction for the city on the south
coast and comparisons between these two
ships can easily be drawn
each one of each wreck has got different
things to offer this is a beautiful big
ship of a certain period which is a
warship your ship is a smaller ship but
it's a trading vessel of a period That's
earlier that's built in a different way
so you know the significances are that
they're both highly significant this is
such an amazing project and I've got to
see it through so even if it takes
decades I'll see this through and
that'll be
uh I don't think I have another one in
me I think I'll just finish this and uh
retire the final pieces of wood will be
transported from Portsmouth back to
Newport today so the building process of
this the world's largest 3D jigsaw can
finally after two decades begin Thomas
Morgan BBC news for CBS Saturday morning
in Newport
to imagine finding something 600 years
old no no and that's size two yeah I
love I love the guy saying you know this
is it you know the incredible amount of
you know intensity putting that together
it's just that's what I was going to say
Jeff said finding it I'm like finding it
putting it back together yeah and then
reconstructing what actually happened
and telling us pretty incredible yeah